[Music]
let's go to joy in
west palm beach what's up joy
hi
how are you i'm so good how are you a
little bit nervous to be honest but
listen here we go i'm not great at this
you're you're good you're good it's good
what's up
um so
my husband and i have been talking about
moving to another state in the next year
or two and currently his younger brother
is living with us
but when we move i'd really prefer if
his brother did not come and i don't
know how to talk to him about it or even
if i have a i have a right to even ask
that
so
man you just told me a lot in like two
sentences
how how much can i unpack that how
what's your what's your permission level
whatever you need to ask
why
in all of the world
do you think you don't have a right to
ask
about who lives in your home
what has happened is home too
it is
but what has happened in that dynamic
between the two of you
that makes you even say that out loud
um well he lives with us
with it was kind of without my
permission
his family had asked
um if he would be able to come live with
us and my husband just automatically
said yes without ever talking to me
about it and so i just kind of feel
thrown into this yeah
how long have you all been married
six years
where else does he do this
um
i mean that's like the biggest thing but
make unilateral decisions just this is
the way we're doing it
um
[Music]
be honest
not i mean he doesn't he doesn't really
do anything like that that
big scale and uh i mean that's like the
biggest thing but i'm talking about
little stuff i mean
yeah
um
sometimes with our
our finances just he i mean like we we
have the same end goal but he doesn't
always the day-to-day he kind of
sometimes loses sight of that and just
or not trying to
you know get us keep us on a budget and
keep us going to the you know where
we're trying to go and he just will be
at a store and see something and go oh i
want to buy this and buy it
so
there
that's probably
i mean that's probably the biggest thing
it took you a lot of courage to call
about this didn't it
yeah yeah
this isn't what you asked me so i'm just
going to answer what you asked me but i
am going to say this
um
and i will admit i have a bias to this
okay
i i
would rather be wrong than right
meaning
um i would rather
hear something that's not really there
on this than to miss it completely
but i hear a little bit of fear in your
voice
a little bit of futility a little bit of
i need to protect him
and i need to keep whatever our story is
our story
and what i want you to hear me say is if
that's the case
please
look in the mirror this afternoon or
this morning whenever you want to
you don't need another guy telling you
what to do
but
i want you to look in the mirror and say
i'm worth
being a co-partner in this deal
and go talk to somebody okay
i may be way out to lunch
but
there's something in your voice that is
setting my radar off okay
and i'm telling you that because i love
you okay
so when it comes to
you've got it how old is this little
brother
he's 17.
okay
so
again in a
quasi-normal dynamic
i would sit down and say
he's been with us for this many years
three years is that right
yes three out of six so 50 of our
marriage has had a teenager in it
that's your brother
i'm ready to have our own home
and so
i am not interested in him
moving with us this time i think we've
done our duty we've done our part
and other people in the house can step
up or he's about to be 18 he is can be
ready to be on his own
and i would like our own house as we
move
that's would be a symbol of conversation
and then probably the pushback would be
no he's my brother he's got to do
whatever and
that's when you would talk more about
the last three years i haven't had a
voice in this i feel like i've not uh
owned i'm not a participant in my own
home
and this is my home too
and i'm all about helping and loving and
if we want to support him financially
and whatever the things are
but i'm ready to have my own home please
and not please in a
please pretty please like like my son
asked me for girl scout cookies but
please as in a
i'm trying to be pleasant as i'm telling
you this is the way i want to move
forward
something tells me you can't have that
conversation you wouldn't be calling me
so what is the conversation like in your
home
well
but we we do have our own kids
and
it's always like oh but
they love him like they love having him
around of course
and i'm like yeah but
i mean it's just and we just
so we have we just had our our third
baby
three months ago so we now have
six of us living in
a two bedroom like 850 square foot
living space
town house what
that's a lot of humans and not a lot of
square footage
exactly
and so that's like another reason why
i'm like i'm ready for our space i'm
ready to have you know i want
my family
yes
what keeps you from saying it out loud
i think i just i feel guilty and like
like
maybe i'm a bad person for not
it's not like i don't want to help him
but at the same time
like i guess i feel like i'm being
selfish where did you learn that
somebody taught you that
that the way you feel and what you need
to make your house whole and what you
need to be well
is selfish
somebody told you that who told you that
i don't know
usually that story is a story that we
are told when we're young we're born
into it
you be quiet this is where we're going
to eat you shut your mouth
you sit back there we don't wear clothes
like that in this house you wear that
only girls who don't care about how they
look eat that stuff don't eat that
we're like this
my little brother's moving in with this
by the way need to make room
and those are stories that are just
dumped into on to us man and so if i'm
the first person to ever tell you this
shame on everyone around you
but you're allowed to have your thoughts
and your feelings and you're allowed to
have your emotions and you're allowed to
say this is what i need to be well
and we have three of our own five people
and 850 square foot feet is a lot
a lot
not to mention a newborn in all the
diapers and breastfeeding and yelling
and crying
that's a lot of humans
and you throw a 17 year old where's his
parents
uh well
they're from another country so his mom
is in their home country and he came to
the us to live with us oh so now we've
got a cultural element on this
yes all right totally different now okay
oh man
just for my own edification are you safe
joy
yes
you promise
yes okay
we often think of safety as physical
safety am i going to get punched in the
eye
i want you to start thinking about
safety also being
spiritual safety psychological safety
does your voice count
can you say hey this is what i need and
i'm heard
now i also want to be i mean
the way i was talking earlier i was
talking very ethnocentric very much
western this is the way we do family
and i know all there's a number of
different cultures that do the family
looks different
right and brothers and sisters and
cousins are all living with us and
that's just the way we do life
what i hope you can do is have a
conversation with your husband about
this is what i need and he will hear
that
but it is absolutely not selfish for you
to be heard for you to state your needs
out loud
in fact that's a gift in fact what i
would tell you is
hurting all day
feeling like you are a stranger in your
own home
distances yourself from your husband
from your kids from family
and so if you i don't think that's i
mean if you want to start thinking
selfish think that way
choosing to not speak up when i don't
feel safe or loved and or connected in
my own house
that's got ramifications too
okay so here's i would take him out i
would have a hard conversation a gentle
conversation a respectful loving
conversation that just says i need i
need to have my own house with my own
family and it's time for your brother to
do his own thing
or at least we got to get a way way way
bigger house with a garage apartment or
something right
when you're moving you're getting a new
place
more space
yeah
yeah well that's the thing too because
if he were to move with us and i feel
like we would need an even bigger house
because he would need his own space
and so i'm just like
thinking about all of the
you know
all of those types of things too
yeah
and it's just
you sound um
you sound lonely
is that the wrong word
no
okay
stay on the line here i'm gonna send you
a copy of
my new book we talk about this stuff all
through it okay not the cultural
challenges that you've got and there is
a cultural gap here
um is your husband usually respectful
when you bring up cultural differences
and you'll say hey how are we going to
navigate this because your fusion
culture's here
and part of using cultures is just
navigating the differences
or does his culture trump every time
you know i think like he's open to
talking about it he just doesn't always
understand
i think he has a hard time really
understanding it okay
and so
i've talked i just fact i just talked
about this in the last podcast
one of the great ways when there's a
miscommunication this way
think about it this way we often
speak in pictures
i mean we speak in words but we think in
pictures okay
so you have a picture of quote unquote
my house
what i feel safe
and you tell your husband i just want my
own house and he's got a picture of what
own house means and it includes cousins
and nephews and brothers and all kind of
people in it it's got a picture of it
and often when we're talking past our
loved ones
it's a matter of painting a new picture
for them
here is a picture it's me being able to
walk around in my own home without a bra
on without a head covering on
in my underwear to go grab something out
of the dryer
being in my own home means not having to
cover up every time i walk out of my
bedroom
it means
that i'm allowed to keep it clean is the
way i want to keep it does that make
sense like you're painting him a picture
of oh i didn't even think about that
i didn't even oh my goodness i didn't
even realize that that i want to have my
friends over i want to have
buddies over with and they bring their
little kids over we want to play we got
the 17 year old here
it's painting a different picture for
for your husband and
um
most of the time if two people love each
other
painting a new picture people go oh my
ah i didn't even see it i'm so sorry and
then there's some grieving like i
totally missed it i'm so sorry
but the other side of it is
man sometimes it's hard and they
somebody says nope they're living with
me
and then you've got a hard decision to
make
i'm going to be really optimistic here
that you got a great husband who is
just absent-minded and hasn't thought
through it didn't even occur to him
the struggles you're going on sharing a
house with
two grown men
right or a grown man and an almost grown
man
and then a new picture paint for him
would be really helpful
thanks for the call joy
and command
three kids and a 17 year old and a
husband and a wife
in a two-bedroom apartment
story at 11. whoo